hey everyone thanks for coming you got a
choice to be in two other rooms and you
chose this one I really appreciate that
and also thanks to the organizers for
the opportunity to speak here is
actually a genuinely a privilege so yeah
thank you so yeah I'm Johnny I'm a data
scientist at the livery and I work in
the merchandising algorithms team so
today I'll be talking to you a bit about
what we do and if you've looked at the
title you'll probably guess it's
something to do with ranking of
restaurants so a little more detail what
I've talked to you about so I'm gonna
introduced the livery for those of you
that don't really know what deliver is
and and introduce why we've started this
this merchandising algorithms team and
then I want to spend some time talking
about our approach to ranking you know
and how it works have it framed the
problem the modeling strategies that
we're using then I want to talk a bit
about the tools so we have to not only
build models but we have to deploy this
and serve these recommendations so how
have we done that what tools have you
chosen and the processes and then
finally I want to finish off with this
section on the lessons that we've
learned you know if we've deployed a few
models run a few experiments and we've
made some mistakes and I want you all to
learn from these so yeah and that's
basically it that's what I want to go
through so here's an introduction so for
those that don't know what the liver is
you can think of it as a platform that
tries to connect consumers to local
restaurants around them and that's
through via an app where you can look
for restaurants and you can order and
then we deliver we have a fleet of
riders and a rider will go pick up the
order so for example if you want to go
in order from Wagga mummers Wagga
murmurs doesn't have their own delivery
fleet so you'd have to go to the
restaurant order and eat there but the
Libero allows you to actually order and
enjoy the food from the comfort of your
own home so you'll go to the app you can
scroll through find Wagga mummers click
order and we'll send the rider off to
the restaurant pick up your food and
then they'll deliver that to your door
so that's the idea and you can probably
tell from the from this slide that it's
a three sided marketplace we have
thousands of thousands of restaurants
and riders and even more consumers in
over 300 cities and in
14 countries so it's a big operation a
huge network so if I'm a if I'm a
consumer and I want to go an order from
the app this is what I might be
presented with so on the left is what
you might see on an app and on the right
you've got the web and basically you've
got a list of restaurants and what we
assume what we are hypothesis is that
depending on the the order of the
restaurants that you see a consumer
might behave differently right you may
or may not order depending on what you
see in that list so enter the
merchandize an algorithms team right we
start with initial goal and we say why
don't we try and present the restaurants
that are most relevant to the consumer
first right because we believe that that
is a thing that's going to be best for
the for that consumer and they might
want to purchase more so that's that's
an introduction to to the to delivery
and a team and what we're trying to do
and so now I want to spend some time
talking about our approach to ranking
this these these restaurants so we've
I've already mentioned the objective
given a list of restaurants user opens
an app there's a local set of local
restaurants right given that how can we
rank them optimally and optimal can mean
many different things and in this case
in our case we want to say that it's
relevant to the user all right so the
question is how do we quantify this it's
all right having an objective but can I
look at some numbers that will help me
understand whether we're actually
achieving the objective of showing the
most relevant restaurants to users so
two of the metrics that we look at is
order volume are we getting more orders
in total over a period of time and the
other one is this session level
conversion and you can think of that as
of the total number of sessions so if a
user goes on the app the of the total
number of times that someone goes on to
the app what proportion of those
actually result in the consumer actually
ordering that's the way you can think of
it so the idea is that these two metrics
the order volume and list session level
conversion if we increase those that's
likely due to the fact that we're
improving the relevance of the of the
is that we're ranking right that's the
idea so this is what we want to improve
so how can we frame the problem the
ranking problem such that we can affect
those metrics such that we can improve
that so here's how we might want to look
at a session so in a session we saw you
have a list of restaurants right and
this can be hundreds of restaurants
right if you're in an area with densely
packed restaurants in a big city like
London you're going to see hundreds of
those and this converted is basically
did you order or not so where we got a
zero a user user didn't not order from
that restaurant and where there's a one
a user did order from the restaurant
right so it's kind of like a target
variable right and that's just one
session but we can have a different user
a different location and they can open
the up as well that's a second session
and so for our training data we take
thousands upon thousands of these
sessions and and that's essentially what
we're looking at and this forms our
target variable so we decided to frame
this ranking problem as a classification
in a classification framework in a point
wise approach and we'll explain what
that means why can we frame this as a
classification problem well what we can
do is we can say ask for each restaurant
in that list we can say what is the
probability that the user will purchase
from that restaurant so that's
independent of it on any other
restaurants in that list we just look at
that restaurant that's what I mean by
point wise right and classification
because we've saw that the the target
variable is either 0 or 1 did you buy
from it or not and then we can then run
for a model and I'll talk about that in
a bit and it will output a score some
probability and then we just ranked in
descending order and that is the rank
that's most relevant to the user all
right so that's that's how we're going
to frame the problem but it means that
because we're looking at this in a point
wise classification fashion that means
we can use a loss function we can use a
logarithmic loss function right just as
we would do in any other standard
classification problem and this so this
is how we're in able to now train models
to tackle our ranking problem but in a
classification framework so I've
discussed the target variable and how we
might train models
but we need some features to go into
that so we might want to look at all the
different factors that might encourage a
user to actually purchase from from from
a restaurant so it might be the
popularity of the restaurant it might be
that if users will purchase for more
popular restaurants or the estimated
time of arrival
perhaps a user really needs some food
within 20 minutes so if there's a 45
minute wait that's not suitable for them
and so and perhaps they look at
restaurant rating and there's loads of
different factors right and we can stick
them into some some box run it through F
its box and output some some probability
score all right and then rank in
descending order but F can be as
complicated as we want right it can be a
simple heuristic or it can be a crazy
dense neural network or whatever it is
but at delivery we have this approach
that we want to start simple and then
just iterate and improve on things so
actually what we initially began with
was just a simple heuristic F was not a
machine learning model it's just a
mixture between the popularity of
popularity rank and the estimated time
of arrival rank and one of the reasons
why why would we do this right so it's
it's simple its intuitive we can
interpret the results much easier but
also we have to serve these results we
have to build an entire infrastructure
to be able to serve these
recommendations sorry this is this
ranking of lists right so with a whole
bunch of moving parts there's a lot that
can go wrong and we want to make sure we
minimize the amount that can go wrong
and so we don't need to concentrate on
the complexity of the model while will
be wily while we build out an
infrastructure right so we started with
a simple heuristic that was good enough
to get started
focus on getting an end-to-end pipeline
in the infrastructure sorted and then we
can start moving on to more complex
models so then we started moving on to
logistic regression models and we're
looking at also more complex neural
network architectures and I'll go over
some of that a bit later so where we got
to we discuss the target variable we've
discussed the features and potentially
models that we'll use right so we saw
that we can get scores just ranked in
descending order and Bob's your uncle we
have a list
right is that rank is that list any good
we have to evaluate that now
we've a frame this as a classification
problem so in theory we could probably
use evaluation metrics like accuracy or
precision but when we think about the
user experience they're not looking at a
single restaurant they are looking at an
entire list so actually we decided it
would make more sense to look at an
information retrieval metric for ranking
which actually tries to take into
account the list itself and importantly
so that's that's one reason we're
looking at information retrieval metrics
the other thing is remember that I said
at the beginning we wanted to look at in
increasing the online metrics the
session level conversion and the order
volume now it's very difficult to go
back in training data or practically
impossible to then say if a user didn't
order in a session now I run from my
model my model then rewrites that list
now they're going to order it's very
important it's very difficult almost
impossible to predict that so offline
when we're training ranking models we
don't evaluate on those online metrics
we need offline metrics which are
proxies for the online so these methods
here are just proxies and if we improve
these metrics we believe we're going to
increase the online metrics so that's
that's the reason why we're looking at
these ones and so there's loads of
there's there's a few different ones I
won't go for all of them but the one
that we decided to go for is this mean
reciprocal rank and explain that what it
is in a second but it's we went for it
because it was fairly simple intuitive
and again we believe it's it would be a
suitable proxy for improving the online
metrics so how would we calculate mean
reciprocal rank for those that don't
have much experience in this let's
suppose we have five sessions right and
on the far left that's our first session
it's got five restaurants and the user
converts or orders from the restaurant
in the fourth position
all right the reciprocal rank of that
would be one over four right in the
second session they order from the
restaurant in a third position the
reciprocal rank one only three right so
we can do that and we can do that for
all of the other sessions that we
trained on and then finally the
mean reciprocal rank is then just the
mean of those numbers alright so then we
get the the final fraction final score
here it's roughly naught point two seven
all right so that would be how we
calculate the mean reciprocal rank over
all the sessions that we trained over in
our training data and we put it in
through our test data as well know
importantly that the mean reciprocal
rank has a maximum score of one and that
corresponds to if we managed to
rearrange the list permute the list in
such a way that the restaurant that the
user ordered from was always placed at
the top position and the idea is that if
we're able to write a an algorithm that
ranks the restaurant that user converts
from at the top of the list then it's
likely that we're doing a good job with
the rest of the list right so and we'll
come back to this we'll come back to
this assumption lessons learned come
back to this assumption but that's
exactly what what we've done that's
that's what we're doing from this point
in time so I've mentioned about the
features the the target variable the
evaluation how does this actually work
in our in our workflow what do we
actually do so like many of you who may
be working on machine learning models we
need to build the Train and test sets
we've got a bunch of sequel that does
that queries from our data warehouse and
we can build our train and test sets
then we have a bit of Python to go and
validate that data so we just want to
make sure how many nulls are there
should there be nails there do we need
to impute what duplicates are there
things like that so we're just trying to
validate that then we go get into
training and so notice we're going to
train on this validated data and we
train loads of different models and the
difference between model one and model
two can just be a removal of one feature
it can be a completely different model
it can be a heuristic it can be a
logistic regression but we train several
different models and each of those
models will have its own permutation of
the list so with a different permutation
I can calculate a mean reciprocal rank
for each one and then as I said before
we just choose the one that gives us the
highest score all right come back to
that but we choose the one that gives us
the highest score and that's the best
model and once we've chosen that
we can then put put all of that into
production right so we run we use a
continuous integration talk with circle
CI that will run a whole bunch of unit
tests for us and then push them some
docker can docker images I should say up
to Amazon s3 and then we have an inbuilt
machine learning a pipeline called canoe
which basically runs this job
periodically each day and so that that's
how we then do that so at that point
we've built some models we've evaluated
them offline right and we've
productionize it great we're in a good
position but the thing is we have not
checked that it's moved our online
metrics we've not checked that let's
move the things that we believe achieves
our objective all right so to do that we
need to run this online we need to run
it and we need to run an a/b test so
what we do is we run a user level
randomization so a user will get a
version of the model so 50% we'll get
the the current version another 50% will
get the new proposed model and we'll run
the ad test look at those online metrics
and see which one actually gives us an
increase in in those metrics and we'll
choose that one right but this is an
iterative process so I said at first we
started with a simple heuristic model
for example that might have been a good
start but then we do a slightly more
complex model and that might win but
then that's still not an optimal model
so then we build an even more complex
and better ranking algorithm so this is
a process that we'd go through over and
over again so we run multiple a B test
is just to try and improve our rankings
so and we're at the point now so that's
that's the whole pipeline of what we do
and how we work and our approach to the
problem and at the moment we're in it
we're in the process of building
slightly more complex models and feature
engineering so as I said we've been
using a lot of logistic regression at
the moment we're currently working
through a wide and deep neural nets as
more complex models but also more
feature engineering so looking at new
features but also embeddings of features
like can we get better representations
of the features that we're already using
to improve our
search results so we still believe it as
there's a lot more that we can do to
improve the rankings that we that we
actually show so that concludes the the
the approach to the ranking problem but
as I said we need to build an
infrastructure that enables us to do
this so I've mentioned a lot of the data
science work but but what about the the
infrastructure that supports this so you
know we're in this in a situation where
actually we need to build something that
can serve features that sometimes are
aggregated and we can get daily or in
advance so we can write some sequel to
get sort of like audit like pass thought
or order volumes and things like that
pass conversion scores but then there
are some features that we don't know
until serve time so the estimated time
of arrival
we can't know prior to the user actually
start an accession and open the app so
there are these things that we have to
consider when we build an infrastructure
to serve this so we considered several
different ways that we could
productionize our models one of the
things that we've done historically in
delivery and one of the things we
considered is let's say that we write
our model and our team writes the models
and does all the analysis in Python we
write a model we've got we've chosen it
it gives us the best mean reciprocal
rank score and then we say okay let's go
and sit down with an engineer and
rewrite that model in the production
language and then the production
language now has a version of that model
in there and that can just serve
straight from there and that's what
we've done in the past but as you can
probably imagine it's a bit slow it's a
time consuming process it's prone to
errors all right if we get the mistake
in copying the the model over but also
the it limits the complexities of the
models that we can we can actually use
all right because we have to implement
it all from scratch so we'd have to
implement like tree base or
neuro-networks from scratch and go if
there wasn't a library for it so we
decided to think okay what's another
method that we can use to productionize
well what about if we didn't need to
rewrite the model in the production
language but instead we wrote modern and
Python and then just
containerized it and released it as a
separate micro service so now the actual
production service that shows you and
renders the homepage would call out to
this Python micro service and then via
some maybe HTTP HTTP interface and then
the the micro service would go rank
restaurants and return it to the
productions never say hey here's a
ranked list of restaurants so that's
cool but remember that actually you
don't want to wait a long time when you
open the app and we were worried about
potential latency problems in making a
lot of requests over the network and
also at busy times where there's a lot
of requests we might need to scale some
containers up and down and actually
figuring out what to scale and when to
scale was going to be slightly difficult
so we went with option three which is
basically to integrate a serialized
version of the model into the production
language so what I mean by that so we
can serialize Python objects so when you
save a Python object it usually use
pickle and then you can read that back
and then you can use the variable again
the problem is pickle can only be read
in Python and our production language
isn't go so what about if we serialized
in a format that to be read from
multiple from different languages and so
we figured well this is the case let's
try and use a framework that would
enable us to do that and which is why we
chose to implement our models
intensively that is the main reason
because it allows us to serialize models
in a format in which we can read from
other production languages but there are
also other benefits that tend to flow so
one it's got it's fairly mature so it's
got a good community it's got good
documentation and so we could guarantee
that there was going to be a good level
of support when we got stuck it includes
a whole range of models so you can
implement linear models in there trees
for the contrib modules but also deep
neural nets and it what isn't much of an
API change and because we're like more
familiar with linear models we were very
interested in using something that could
serve linear models but also allow us
enable us to easily go more complex and
also it has this what's called the
estimator API I want to explain that
because I wasn't familiar with
until we started looking into tensorflow
but it basically the idea is to give an
interface that allows you to write
models similar in fashion to how you
wouldn't psyche it then so I don't
usually like putting code up on screen I
promise I don't but I don't need you to
focus on the code I just want you to
focus on on what bits this is so this is
like an example of how the tensorflow
estimator API might work so basically
the first thing you need to do is define
how the Daito needs to flow into the
model so if I have like a let's say a
CSV or a panda's data frame of the data
I need to say oh I want a thousand
observations to go in in each batch I
want to shuffle that batch because I
want to randomize the data and all that
so we write a function I haven't put it
in there because I couldn't be bothered
and I want it to feel on-screen we then
need to create features so tensorflow
needs to know where their features
numeric because it might want to scale
it or if it's categorical because it
might want to do one hot encodings or
embeddings by the last two bits what
make the estimated estimator API
familiar to us so with if I want to use
a logistic regression classifier I just
do tf2 estimated linear classifier right
in a similar fashion to two scikit-learn
right and then again if I want to train
it I can now do classifier train right
which is analogous to the classifier
don't fit in scikit-learn and
importantly if you have used low-level
tensorflow before and you've remembered
that like crit and placeholder variables
you can run multiple sessions and it's
just it's just a headache I don't need
that in your life right so this this
enables us to not worry about any of
that stuff it doesn't we don't have to
worry about creating those variables and
we can train models in in a simple
fashion and if I want to switch to a
deep neural net in the estimator API I
can change linear classifier to DNN
classifier for example and just add a
few more arguments so now we can change
some more complex models in a very very
simple way and then importantly the
other big the other important thing to
remember is that we need to in like
right inference and go
are there any go writers a new like goes
any audience okay a few like I've tried
I've tried here I don't right go
but this is roughly how it would be done
right laughter you know so you import
the tensorflow
modern go you can write function get
model it just needs to download the
serialize model that comes out but
importantly here so model dot session
not run so it's a similar interface in
another in another language and then it
takes as the first input the the feed
dict for anyone that's familiar with
tensor flow we've put in the the input
features and then the next argument is
the fetches so the node in the tensor
flow graph that says okay I actually
want to get the probabilities from the
logistic logistic regression classifier
so that's the output node and then
you've got your results inference it's
great it's great so this is how we
actually read from the serialize model
in go so at the start this section I was
talking about the different approaches
to productionize in the model like the
different considerations and one thing
we're looking into is how something like
Amazon sage maker can help us improve
that flow because it's still a bit of
friction in doing that there's still a
few hoops and hopefully we can use its
tools help out with that but
additionally sage maker even if it
doesn't change things on the production
world it helps with parallelizing model
training and also hyper parameter
optimization so we're looking at using
this for several different parts of our
workflow so yeah really stages of that
but awf AWS has been very helpful so far
cool all right so we looked at the
approach to modeling my ranking of
disgusts how we train evaluate and then
also the tools how we built the
infrastructure to do this and we've
deployed several models we've run
several a B tests and we've made several
mistakes and so I just want to devote
the last section of this talk to some of
the lessons that we've learned and if
there's anything that you take away like
I hope that these are going to be able
to help you in some of your projects as
we go forward so the first one is even
though your production areas
your model you serialize a model and
everything works in your training
environment you also have to serve this
and actually when you serve it there may
be bugs in a in a data science code
there may be bugs in the in the
engineering code and so you can actually
get different results different ranks in
production to your ranks in training and
you won't know it and you know when we
started some times we didn't we didn't
actually check this at first and when we
were starting to see different ranks or
different results what's going on
something simple we can do is just check
the train service queue check that
production actually matches what you
expect in your training environment so
this is I showed you one here that's
perfect we check the ranks on production
versus offline I don't write bugs in
code so this is perfect if they all land
on y equals x then we have a perfect
rank so our production ranks match
training right but actually if we see a
scatter here that means something's gone
wrong
right so something's different so then
we also have to check the features so
for example if I go onto my phone and we
serve a ranking a rank list I can see an
estimated time of arrival of let's say
20 minutes
all right that's that's what I use we'll
see and then the next day that goes into
a warehouse and I can write sequel to
generate a dataset so now my sequel gets
the estimated time of arrival for that
same user and session and it might not
be 20 minutes and so we want to check
that when we run our sequel for our
training data it actually matches the
inputs that are going in in production
and so here is is what we can see like
four features here that did not match
what we saw in production and the
proportion of times that it did not
match and so looking at these things can
really help actually find bugs sometimes
it may not be in the code that you've
written more often is more is in my code
but but sometimes it can be an
engineering code as well and this can
help find where those problems might be
and we can fix them so doing this every
time and setting up so it's actually
part of the pipeline can be very very
time
like time-efficient i'll come back to
that later log and monitor everything
right so if there's a number you know
you need log it if you're not sure log
it if you collect the number and you
don't think you need it
log it right I promise you it's it's
just so important so like the example
I'm just going to use to like explain it
so you know we have to write sequel to
get the sessions from yeah get session
data so we can train models right and
that runs every day and over the last
few months delivery has started to like
revamp and change the backend to to the
to the home page and so it meant that
the tracking changed and we didn't love
this and so for week for a week we were
starting to miss theta because the
sequel columns were matching it they
were all nulls we didn't love this
things we didn't really look at it and
and what we then saw was at the point at
which the training data period was
completely messed up that's when we got
an error saying our model in train today
it turned out this was like actually a
problem for quite a while and we just
weren't seeing it and so he actually
didn't had to go back but the only thing
is you've all you've got is your your
looks that's all you've got
so we have to start from the training
script where actually we just saw the
modeled in train but actually the
problem was way back sequel wasn't
collecting the data so it was a few
scripts down and it actually wasn't a
change that we'd made it was a change on
the backend for the engineers we didn't
actually change any of our code but
things went wrong and if we had logged
everything and had monitored everything
we would have caught it much earlier so
if there's numbers that you don't you're
not sure that you need just just game
now just get him down it can save you a
whole bunch of time and here's one I'm
gonna come back to you so I mentioned to
you that we run many models calculated
mean reciprocal ranks and we said the
best one was the one that gave us the
highest score that's actually not always
true and it can be very misleading in
fact there were times where we saw an
a/b test that we had increased with
really
the model to increase the meanness of
pool rank but none of our online metrics
actually changed right and this this is
led us to start to include what other
what are the limitations of mean
reciprocal rank well actually it only
assesses the single session that was
converted it says nothing about the rest
of the restaurants in that list right we
made an assumption that we were if we
could put one restaurant at the top we
were doing well with the other
restaurants right that's not that
assumption fell through right and so
actually we figured we needed to start
to look at several different metrics so
there's no one single metric that we're
that we're not looking at anymore so one
of the things we go and do is we look at
again scatter plots so let's look at
what are the ranks of the current
algorithm versus the ranking of a new
proposed algorithm right if they lie on
the line y equals x and they're
completely identical well then if you
release an a/b test you're not going to
see any changes because the ranks are
identical and so actually we can tell
why how much scatter is in these plots
and we can quantify it with the
Spearman's rank correlation coefficient
like how different ranks of models are
so now we can actually start to to
determine determine in advance how
different we what differences we might
expect in an a/b test the other thing
that we find incredibly useful is
actually looking at the surface you're
changing so we're actually changing the
ranks when we released this model what
the user sees what is their experience
they see a rank of restaurants so
looking at a global metric you are not
you're not actually looking at what the
customer experiences and so actually
what we end up doing some of the
engineers and our team built this
ranking insights visualizer and we
released it to all employees is that we
can actually is not very clear on there
but you can like switch between
different models that we have in
production and actually look at what
ranks you'd expect and you can put in
different locations different postcodes
to see where the ranks make sense and
this is incredibly important because if
I now look at this and I can see at
dinner time I'm getting breakfast
restaurants at the top of the list maybe
I haven't accounted for time properly in
in the model so this looking at things
like
this can help us really understand the
changes that we need to make in a model
to improve our recommendations our
rankings so it's just something that we
use as a cinch check and finally if
you've not read Google's rules of
machine learning online go and read them
and if you read on what's before read
them again like I find it incredibly
useful actually not just me but like
other members in a team to go back to
this like you know two months down the
line three months because actually some
of the rules make so much more sense
after you've seen them and you've gone
through the issues and you're like
actually if I just done that earlier I
would have would have caught the problem
and so yeah so go back and read that so
in summary of the lessons learned check
the differences between training them
and and production environments right it
will ultimately speed things up and we
can actually check that we're making the
impact that we want right if we can
check that our models are working
accurately then they'll have the impact
on the metrics that we want the other
thing log and monitor all the things
everything it's so useful don't just
rely on global metrics as well
right so global metrics are fantastic
they're good regression use our MSE or
whatever use accuracy whatever you want
but don't just rely on them actually
look at some of the predictions
themselves make sure that the the
predictions you're making make sense and
finally rule read googles Wars of
machine learning so yeah just to wrap up
and in rehash everything I've just said
so in a team we we had initial name aim
to like improve the restaurant ranking
and we wanted to improve the relevance
of the restaurants to to the consumers
and and we built an infrastructure to do
that and we've built a bunch of models
and along the way we've made mistakes
and we've learned so much from it
and there's still more to learn I'm sure
there's there's gonna be a lot more
pitfalls there maybe next year I'll come
back and talk about a few more who knows
but we've actually got work to do
because we're trying to expand what
we're doing so that's just ranking of
the restaurant list but there are other
things that you want to do ultimately we
want to algorithmically design and
create the best experience for the
consumer we might want to touch
different services so we need to look at
search results and filter
the horizontal scrolling carousels you
might see like Oh order again or is some
discounts and stuff like that so we
actually want to try and start to do
algorithms that will affect the whole
experience but that's not all we do you
can probably tell now that I'm starting
to get to there to the you know
promoting delivery here that's not all
we do yeah all of you know there are
other algorithm seems right we have we
need to work out how much should should
like fees all right how should we set
them you know we've got a network and
the network's different in different
places and we order from different
places which are further away you know
should it should it change thank you
logistics I've mentioned me at a start
we have a three sided marketplace with a
ton of restaurants and riders and
consumers and they're everywhere you
know how can we make sure that this
network runs efficiently you know
there's a lot of complicated problems
there and also we run a whole bunch of
a/b tests whole bunch of experiments I'm
not first to finish we want a whole
bunch of experiments and so actually
it's we want to try and standardize this
process and get out there so we're
building an experimentation platform so
come and help us do this and obviously
guys we're hiring join us where our
stand at the entrance to the big room at
the back I'm gonna be there after this
talk and to the to the end of the day
and they'll be at least one data
scientist and a recruiter on there all
day today and and tomorrow's world's
come see us and finally thank you for
listening
[Applause]
epic talk the so I've also done some
recommenders and I've also sort of
noticed that like there's these proxies
and they don't necessarily correlate
with real life have you found any
proxies that do so not perfect actually
I've been trying to read like quite a
few different recommendation articles
and papers to see if there are like good
offline metrics that better represent
online I haven't seen any one of the
things that we've done in our team but
we just need to do a few more experience
is we're trying to actually correlate
offline metrics with what results we get
in experiments and so because we run
experiments we do have online number
theta points what it was each experiment
on its own is one data point and so we
need to run quite a few to get to build
that correlation we can calculate things
like online meanness that will rank
online precision at K but yeah the short
answer is we haven't yet found it but I
think the the work will do in
correlating those will hopefully help
but it's not perfect no hard questions
thanks for the great talk I'm glad you
said that
Mrowr has limitations and really happy
that you had that on your slides so I
had a comment any question so what the
comment is mr are is hard to interpret
because for example the difference
between putting the relevant restaurant
in rank one and rank two is exactly the
same as putting the relevant restaurant
and trying to and Rec infinity so I
wonder if you see interesting patterns
in the data similar to what I described
and also if you if you're going to use
precision at cave for example what
evaluate of K would you use in your case
alright so first question
I mean reciprocal rank do we see so as
you can imagine with it being reciprocal
if you place a
the restaurant at position one you get a
meanness of course go of one if you
place at position two it's now half if I
place it at position three is 0.33 so
the difference is although we're still
moving the restaurant in the same amount
the difference is between the scores
change right so it's it's it's not
perfect how do we account for this I
personally and and this is a thing so I
think I evaluate in these recommendation
systems and ranking systems in my
opinions quite subjective I like to
think of the mean reciprocal rank as
thinking about it as almost like a
threshold like if you can get a mean
reciprocal rank which is a point two
that means on average you're placing the
restaurant in the fifth position right
so you're doing fairly good there but
once you get to that point I think if
you start getting ones that are lower
maybe that's not good enough and so
actually once I start getting minima
cyclical ranks of more than point two
I'm starting to think that there's not
much difference in the ranks and
actually what's more important is
looking at the ranks done individually
set for me looking at the scatters and
starting to assess whether actually it
looks like it's learned something
because now I can see that breakfast
time I'm seeing a whole bunch of
breakfast restaurants it's not perfect
but I
we've not settled on any good way to
rank that precision at K we this was
some of the work when we were
correlating the online metrics with the
offline we found that thirty
seemed to be best for the data points we
had but I don't think I had enough data
points to be able to say that firmly so
no one quote me saying thirty is the
best but that's what it looked like but
for me intuitively I think thirty would
be too much I actually think we'd want
to sell it lower because I think when I
think about when you think I just think
about having a session how many how many
restaurants do you scroll through before
you evaluate where a list is any good do
I need to evaluate through all 30 so do
users do that I I actually don't know
and we're like implementing scroll
tracking to start to see what they're
seeing but yeah it's hard to know I mean
so yeah I can answer
you you mentioned bit as a marketplace
of three three parties but your goal is
very focused on one do you have any
thoughts about how you would extend the
work you've done to maybe it might be
something they're taking and how it
benefits of riders or new restaurants
like cetera yes so I'll try me
relatively quick because I know we're
running out of time yes it only focuses
on one and actually the change we've got
to make is in the objective function I
read a paper very recently by Spotify
it's called towards a fair marketplace
read it if you're doing any ranking
problems they looking at relevance to
the user
fairness to the artists so that would be
like fairness to the restaurants around
us and actually what is satisfaction for
the user and can they balance fairness
and relevance to get the best
satisfaction I think that we can change
the objective function so that we can
like show users more restaurants that
are of a wider variety but where we're
still early days in the haven't got to
that point but yeah
[Applause]